hey what's up my name's Samuel Leeds
welcome back to my channel and in this
video you're in for a treat because I am
going to be sitting down interviewing my
property tax accountant so I'm going to
be asking them all about capital gains
tax how to save taxes a property
investor joint ventures Partnerships you
are going to love this video so if you
enjoy the channel do me a favor hit the
like button below don't forget to
subscribe and welcome Courtney and
Richard hi thank you so much for coming
down from gorillas accountancy you've
traveled from Bolton and you guys are
literally about to run a marathon in a
couple of days
Psychopaths I don't know what it is with
my solicitor accountants mortgage
brokers everybody in my power team seems
to be like really into extreme sports
and Marathon running and stuff like that
um but no really appreciate you coming
down and good luck on your marathon on
Sunday thank you thank you good to be
here yeah awesome so why don't you stop
by just telling me a little bit about
the importance of tax and why it's
important to have an accountant and good
people around you when you're running
any kind of business but particularly
property it's really important on
because you know actually paying an
accountant you could end up saving quite
a bit money in tax and there's quite a
few things that you really need to be
thinking about the right way to
structure your business for example
limited or personally owned or
partnership and also the expenses that
you can claim which can really sort of
make a difference between a high and a
lot much lower tax bill and also when
you understand things like we were
talking earlier about
um bedroom relief tax which we'll talk
about but when you understand certain
things that you can do and where you
don't even have to pay any tax at all it
opens the doors up and you can stop
being a bit more entrepreneurial and
having a bit more of a flare about you
so um okay well why don't we start from
the beginning why don't you talk to me
about one of the most obvious ways to
save tax is to expenses so if you're if
you're if you're making you know um ten
thousand pounds a month from your rent
you're gonna claim all of your expenses
as tax deductible and a lot of people
don't realize what they can and what
they cannot claim so to talk to me about
some of the things that you can and you
can't claim and as tax deductible as a
property investor okay yeah so mainly
anything that you can think of that
you've incurred for renting out the
property you can claim for so I'm
talking even traveling to the business
you can have all your repairs and the
maintenance of that business cleaning it
the accountancy fees because like we
said you do want an encounter gas
certificates your legal fees letting
agents fees anything along those lines
the only thing that you probably can't
claim for is if used to enhance that
property so that would then be what's
called a capital
a capital expense so you can't get full
allowable expenses on that
um but if you was to repair things or
you was to replace something like a
light for like replacement then that is
allowable okay interesting did you want
to add anything to that yeah I mean
there's quite a few other bits and
pieces but obviously one that's might be
of interest to your viewers would be
training costs so if you have any
training that relates to the business
that you you working through that
enhance your skills that relate to that
property business then those could be
claimed as well and talk to me through
a question I get asked all the time
should you be investing through a
company or should you just buy as a as
an individual and what are the pros and
cons to each well if your company there
are some more obligations so you need to
file accounts each year with companies
house and file cooperation tax return as
well as your self-assessment which you
would be doing anyway
um but it can be there can be a tax
saving there and there's a few reasons
for that so the first one is
um the the tax rate for corporate
profits is 19 so for example if you're a
higher ed taxpayer you've already gonna
be paying 40 on your income and profits
that you would get so there's a
potentially a tax saving there that can
be used to reinvest uh in property if
that's your intention
um so yeah the limited company can be a
better route for that there's also the
mortgage interest so a few years back
there was a change to the whether the um
the the expense for mortgage interest
was treated for personally on onto
properties and there's a restriction on
that that's 20 percent so that's the tax
relief so it can be a lot more
advantageous to go with the limited
company but it does differ from each
person so what would say is get the tax
advice that's tailored to you personally
and what about if you've got properties
already like as you know I've got a lot
of properties that I bought in my
personal name before section 24 was even
a thing because it didn't come into full
effect until 2020 if you've got
properties in your personal name and
you've now been hit with section 24 tax
is it worth it or is it beneficial to
move your properties over to a limited
company to save with the section 24.
well typically when you're having when
you're limited company buys the property
to yourself you're going to incur things
like your stamp Duty again all your
legal fees so it's actually best at
weighing up your options typically if
you're going to purchase a property and
set it up by your limited company you
would probably do that from the get-go
of the purchasing that of the initial
purchase of the property yeah
um so again if you're thinking of doing
anything like that speak to your
accountant because you need to assess
your personal situation yeah and your
other personal income to find whether
you should be purchasing it through a
limited company or getting that
personally yeah you could you could end
up being hit with the stamp users twice
really when you buy the initial property
initially and then when your company
purchase it from from you personally so
that's the thing you need to weigh up
whether it's worth taking that hit I'm
going with a limited company or just
thinking look I'll keep these properties
personally anything in the future I'll
buy through the limited company yeah and
I think generally speaking the former is
usually what happens because you're
effectively having to sell the
properties aren't you because it's not a
case of moving it into a company you
have to sell it to the company and then
you're gonna incur all the costs that
come with selling a property exactly so
yeah that's it there's there's a cost
from selling it yourself so solicitors
fees and also
um the stamp Duty and fees the the uh
the company would pay for purchase it
from you so there's two big costs
generally speaking that you have to pay
tax wise as a property investor the
first is your income tax so if you're
getting a lot of rent coming in you have
to pay tax on that and we've talked
about ways to save that incurring
expenses claiming back your expenses
such as training courses all the things
that you can also paying yourself
through a company so that you can pay
yourself tax effectively as well which
is great but the big expense that can
come up tax wise is also capital gains
tax because if you buy a property and
you bought it back in 2009 2010 like how
I bought a lot of my properties they've
allowed tripled in value so if you want
to actually get that money from the
property and you sell it you're going to
get hit with capital gains tax which is
a very high a high percentage so could
you guys talk to me a little bit about
capital gains tax and ways to navigate
through that and to potentially make
that as as prudent as possible yeah
definitely and so with with capital
gains tax if it's through a company
you're still going to pay that 9 18 tax
and that this this arises when you sell
an asset so you know one of your
investment properties will be classed as
a as an asset now if you're on the the
property personally and the rates are 18
if you're basically at taxpayer and then
it goes to 28 for anything over that
however there is a 12 300 pounds
tax-free capital gains allowance so if
you are selling property it's worth
bearing that in mind because that's
available each tax year so you might
want to sort of think about when you
sell your properties and the timing
because you can use that each tax year
if you were to sell two properties it
might be worth doing one in one tax year
and then the next in the next tax year
so you can make use of the capital gains
tax free allowance in each year and that
makes sense that's why a lot of
portfolio landlords if someone's got 20
houses and they decide what I want to
sell up they sell one property every
year for tax reasons yeah which is why
when we come in and we offer them lease
option agreements so we'll say well why
don't you agree to stay on now with us
we'll buy all your 10 houses and we'll
stagger it over the next 10 years and
then of course we take control benefit
from the rent and any potential Capital
depreciation so that's that's the reason
that landlords do that because they they
they're getting that 12 000 or or
whatever it is exactly
um tax-free with capital with capital
gains tax what are some other ways to
potentially avoid paying that staggering
so if you've got a property and you've
say you bought it for 100 grand it's now
worth 300 and you want to get some
Equity but you don't want to get hit
with taxes are there anything else that
you can do yeah so what you could
actually do is instead of selling that
property on and receiving the profit you
can just refinance it and then you can
take the money out that way so it's not
actually a sale so you're not actually
gaining profit you just basically
getting a bigger Finance on the property
yeah yeah and if also another thing to
mention if you've lived in the property
at all there are some tax reliefs on
that so if it's your main residence then
potentially there won't be any capital
gains tax to pay at all or if you have
I've lived in it at any point it may
reduce the capital gains tax that's
that's due on that that's correct so for
those people that move into a house
maybe a couple move into a house they
live in it they buy it cheap they do it
up and then they sell it they flip it
they're not paying any tax at all
because it's their residence yeah and
even if they moved in between a moving
out and then going into a new property
and then selling the property you get in
the private residence relief for the
last nine months before the sale and
then or if you're not living in it as
you said Courtney refinance it and I
don't understand why more people don't
do this because if you sell it and
you're going to get hit with say 25 28
capital gains tax you have more money in
your pocket if you refinanced it on a 75
loan to value you've got more money in
your pocket and you're keeping the
property yeah we see that and it's it's
worth thinking about because you can
invest in a property we sometimes see
them in you know people move it will
make property into uh multiple dwellings
for example the property value will then
be worth more they can refinance the
property at that point use that funds
and that's released from refinancing to
invest in more property yeah yeah
absolutely brilliant what did you think
of the new stamp Duty announcement from
Liz trust recently it's great news I
think you know it's always good that the
the allowances has increased you know
for people looking to buy property never
going to turn it down are we no and I
think I think it's gonna because because
house prices have been going crazy for
the last two three years they've been up
and up and up and up and just as though
we're beginning to sort of tail off a
little bit and become a bit more
stagnant they do this in the new in the
new budget which I think is going to
give another boost yet again to house
prices which is quite exciting really
for especially people entering into the
market yeah especially like first-time
buyers as well yeah like particularly
people in my situation it just makes it
a lot more appealing because a first
house that is less than 250 that 50 000
pounds it's going to be more appealing
because they've got less additional fees
to pay on top of it yeah talk to me a
bit about when you're bought when you're
buying properties is there a reason to
set up multiple companies per purchase
that you do do you need lots of
different companies to be a property
investor not necessarily no it just all
depends on
um your plan if you're planning to set
up a portfolio how many shareholders you
want with each different company
um sorry with each different property so
you may have different shareholders or
investors so you may want to have the
multiple companies so they can have the
different share structure yeah so if
you've got joint ventures for instance
with lots of different individuals then
you might have a new company per
transaction but there's not a limit that
you can have you can have as many
properties as you want in one company
right yeah of course there's just
something to be aware of you might have
to do something called frs1 ort which is
slightly larger accounts but that's only
if your balance sheet goes over a
certain value and you turn over and is
over a certain amount and if you have
more than 10 employees so there is that
considerable it is quite a large amount
I believe that to two accounts had to
speak to accountants they'll know what's
uh the accounting and filing
requirements are for your business
accounts and sometimes it's not worth
trying to be too clever clever like I
know there's some people that are trying
to save on that so they set up another
company and it's like just take just
accept that you're you're growing and
and just accept that and you can always
the bigger you grow the more expenses
you can claim back like we climb back
part of this house as tax deductible
because we've got a an office here and
you know we're getting a studio so it's
about being really creative about how
you can bring your tax bill down but
northern properties are in one company
as well because it's all under the same
roof what can happen is if you make a
loss on a
um one property you can actually offset
that against your gains yeah of another
property whereas if it was in separate
companies that wouldn't be an option
yeah also as well um as you know I like
holiday lets and service accommodation
shorts short stay let's there's a lot of
advantages to that because a tenant will
have a lot of Rights whereas if you've
got guests and they're in a holiday that
they haven't got the same type of rights
that tenants have but it's also great
from a tax perspective could you talk to
us a little bit about holiday let's and
some of the things that you can claim
back as tax deductible through holiday
lets yeah it will potentially generate
more expenses that can be pulled into
the holiday lights which wouldn't be
sort of available for the normal rental
property there's things that you would
there are extra costs that you may be
incurring so such as letting agent fees
for advertising the holiday lets
cleaning of the property but there are
other things that really wouldn't
possibly be available for other things
like you know if you're doing things
like renovating fitting out the kitchen
and these are all tax deductible costs
adding heating systems really getting it
ready to be let out as a holiday let
um you know these extra expenses and
other things like Bank interests and so
on if it's a holiday like business so
basically you can
you get Capital allowances on a lot of
the
um on a lot of the expenses when you're
making the property in good standard is
that what you're talking about yeah
that's right and because possibly with
uh those are extra sort of costs that
you could bring into your income tax
calculation for the year the capital
allowances so you'll then claim that
back and over time when you're getting
your income exactly rather than you know
it being added to the sort of cost of
the property and then all they're coming
into the capital gains tax calculation
which you may only see years down the
line
you decided to sell it exactly yeah
exactly and I think it is important
having people around you a good a good
firm of accountants that can advise you
on this stuff because if you not only
can you save a lot of money but also if
you do it wrong and you think you think
you're being clever but actually what
you're doing is not correct because you
can end up getting fines and you can end
up having to cough up that money that
you thought you'd save from the hmrc
exactly yeah you know it's really
important to us that things are filed
correctly you know you get the right
advice but also if you can make a tax
evidence well you know that's extra
money in your pocket for you know future
investment yeah and the thing I don't
understand is people think that when
you're saving on tax and you're legally
and ethically avoiding tax that it's
um the government and the hmrc won't
like that but actually they do like it
because usually the way to save tax is
to follow the incentives that they give
you for instance they want us to have
electric cars so they incentivize us the
things that they want us to do if we
just follow them and understand what the
what the government wants
um then then that's one of the best best
ways to save tax yeah they don't call
them reliefs or allowances for no reason
they're not they're not trapped there
yeah they're there for a relief or yeah
to allow you a taxi and you don't have
to do anything dodgy to save money on
Tax
anything that helps the trade of the
business in the long run is going to
bring more tax in you know the more
successful a business is the better the
company does and you know that's going
to bring more tax in overall for the uh
the treasury in hmrc and there's lots of
things that my students are doing making
money and they think they have to pay
tax on they're getting money but
actually they don't realize they don't
have to pay any tax like for instance
um renting a room out in your house
could you talk to me a little bit about
renter rent a room relief yeah of course
so what happens is you've got your house
like here and you could just rent out
one room to
um typically what you know as a lodger
and and they will basically have access
to all of your house but they will
reside within one room they can pay you
rent for that room and as long as you
don't receive more than 7500 in one year
then it's absolutely tax-free so you
basically if you're living in a house
you rent out a spare room they pay you
seven and a half Grand a year in rent
and you just pay no tax on that at all
absolutely incredible absolutely
incredible
um I wanted to ask you a little bit
about training costs because one of the
questions that I get a lot is when
people are signing up to my courses
they'll say can I claim this back and
how long do I have to claim it back
um of course I know that they can
because if they're setting up a property
business and it's going to enhance their
skills as a property investor but I just
wanted to hear it from the horse's mouth
and hear a little bit about that talk to
me about can you claim back training
courses as tax deductible well hmrc
actually are very specific advice on
this it's to enhance a skill that you've
got and for the trade of what you're
working on so if you're in the property
business and you're doing training
courses to help you run that business
and improve the business then that cost
is fine if you're in a property business
and you do it like for example a baking
course then that's not going to be
allowable so to enhance the skills that
you've got and relating to the actual
business trade that you're doing great
my advice to my clients is should hmrc
ever come along and inquire into your
taxis if you're happy to sit there and
justify that that training cost is
specifically for the need of the
business and it enhances a skill that
you've already got then yeah so in other
words if you if you go on a course to
learn about bakery or dog walking you're
not going to be able to that clearly
isn't going to enhance you in your
business but if you've got a property
company or a deal sourcing or you're
doing rent to rents or
flipping houses and you go on a course
that's going to help you with that then
it's very clearly it's a it's a tax
deductible expense and it's the same for
us we're accountants so that's our trade
we have subscriptions we need to do
training training courses to keep up to
date with skills keep up to date with
tax law you know that's relates to our
business and at the trade that we do
those are allowable costs for for us and
for Guerrilla accounting that's great
final question a lot of my property
deals and a lot of my students that I
teach do joint ventures so they'll buy a
house with somebody else so it might be
a case of one of my students gets really
good at finding houses they'll find the
house they'll put the team together
they'll do all the work but they'll get
a joint venture partner that puts the
money in and they'll go 50 50 on the
profits how would you as tax accountants
advise an operation like that or a deal
like that to be legally structured and
how would you get that a company like
that formed so there's you can have it
as a partnership but we think that
Legacy company is the best way to go
um you can have the shareholding however
you want so we normally say set up a
company with 100 shares 100 shares you
can have a percentage however you likes
or what if it's 50 50 50 50 70 30 70 30.
so you can set set up the shares however
you like in that limited company based
on your agreement
and then what can happen the investor
might want to put the money in is a loan
to the company and then any profits from
the sale would be split as per the
shareholding so that would be pre-agreed
we advise you to get legal advice on you
know if there's any contracts involved
and just to to make sure that you know
you're protected but the any more money
from the investor that's put into the
company's loan would then be taken out
and then any profits would be split as
per the shareholding incredible awesome
well thank you so much guys for coming
down and sharing I really appreciate it
if you've got any final words of advice
for somebody wanting to to make money in
property that's thinking about beginning
to think about tax
get the right advice because you know
it's worth speaking to an accountant you
know it really is and do it from the
start because you know if you structure
your business either all in it
personally or limited company just think
about how you're going to do that from
the start get the right advice so you're
on the right path and uh you know
working in the right way Guerrilla
accounting can help with that there we
go how do we reach out Courtney if
people want to get in touch simply
search gorilla accounting
um on Google you'll see our website and
straight away there is an option to
speak to our new business team so you
can arrange a call or you can go via
emails awesome well I really appreciate
you coming down today all the way from
Bolton guys if you found that useful do
us a favor hit the like button if you've
got further questions or you want me to
do a part two and delve into other
things then just comment your questions
below or of course reach out to gorilla
accountancy I will leave their details
in the description below and look
forward to seeing you guys next time
thanks for watching
foreign
[Music]